consomme avec grégory chakir porte
parole du collectif inter bloc
infirmiers au chu de toulouse bon soir
grégory fait qu'il remercie d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france sans bien
sûr crier victoire quels sont les
indicateurs d'une amélioration ce que
vous voulez le constater sur place dans
votre hôpital
bonsoir oui on peut dénoter qu'il ya une
baisse au niveau du taux d'admission des
patients qu'aux vide dans la région
après c'est pas non plus généraliser il
ya des régions encore où le taux stagne
et d'autres où le taux continue
légèrement à augmenter donc il faut être
prudent quand même quant à ces chiffres
il ya quand même toujours le virus qui
circule et un taux d'admission qui reste
sans ciment est toujours élevé mais
c'est ça reste quand même en baisse dans
certaines régions et c'est plutôt
encourageant pour la suite des
évènements vous l'attribué 'à quoi vous
la politique de restriction confinement
touvre feu oui un peu à tous après ce
sont des mesures on va dire de dernier
recours un cd mesures urgentes 1 c'est
ça dénote bien une chose c'est que
l'hôpital surtout est en crise et que
depuis des années comment le dénonce
avec le collectif le collectif inter
bloqués l'hôpital manque de moyens et on
est obligé d'en arriver à des d'un
confinement généralisé de la population
pour pouvoir faire face à une épidémie
c'est ce que c'est ce que c'est ce
qu'ont dénoncé ce qui est ce qui est
dommageable
on parle évidemment là on est à la
deuxième vague
on a atteint le pic comme le dit olivier
viron est-ce que vous en tant que
soignant vous créé n'est justement déjà
une troisième vague est ce que vous ne
pourriez y faire face dans vos hôpitaux
bien évidemment après il faut aussi
faire la part des choses il n'y a pas
que l'épidémie qu'ovide il ya aussi
d'autres d'autres épidémies a notamment
la grippe et la gastro entérite en fait
il ya d'autres choses donc on se
focalise beaucoup sur le sur la coved
il faut pas oublier aussi le reste de la
prise en charge des patients et
notamment blocs opératoires et il faut
savoir qu'on a déprogrammé massivement
des chirurgies alors que des patients
étaient en attente et d'opérations
durant durant de nombreux mois
donc il ya une perte réelle de chance
pour ces patients là et qu'on oublie
totalement de 2,2 de dire et de
de publier donc sur dans les médias
c'est intéressant ce que vous nous dites
clairement vous refusez d'autres
opérations comme on l'a vu dans ce pour
la première vague les opérations
importantes a clairement et non non il
faut maintenant je pense qu'il faut
arrêter de déprogrammer les
interventions çà s'est on l'avait déjà
nous signaler lors de la première vague
si on peut appeler ça une première vague
parce qu'on sait que le virus mute aussi
donc ce sont des ce sont des vagues
différentes mais en tout cas clairement
nous on avait dit non c'est déjà cette
déco cette déprogrammation massive dans
les hôpitaux
durant la première première vague ce qui
avait contraint les blocs opératoires à
fermer des salles et donc des prises en
charge retardé pour les patients il faut
se souvenir qu'avant le co lead les
délais d'attenté pour la chirurgie était
déjà important et très élevé notamment
pour certaines spécialités où il fallait
attendre plusieurs mois voire presque
une année pour être opéré mais les
patients donc n'ont pas pu être pris en
charge chirurgicalement à la première
vague est donc à la seconde vague
ce qui fait qu'il ya une réelle perte de
chance pour certains et même des décès
malheureusement à la clé pour pour
certains patients
aujourd'hui
on a évité ce qui s'est passé notamment
dans le grand est à la première vague le
tri de certains patients au nom disait
ça n'a plus lieu d'être aujourd'hui lors
de cette deuxième vague on a quand même
un petit peu mieux gérées selon vous
mais comme je viens de vous le dire on a
quand même été contraint de déprogrammer
massivement dans certaines régions et
notamment sur paris ou à lyon entre 70
et 80% de l'activité chirurgicale
donc on a fatalement les médecins et les
équipes soignantes et au bloc opératoire
où étaient contraints de faire des choix
puisque la grosse problématique en plus
on va dire à part du coc vide c'est la
problématique de l'hôpital public en
général et c'est une c'est une
problématique qui dure déjà depuis de
nombreuses années ce n'est pas une
problématique est récente
on avait déjà nous dénoncer avec
l'intersyndicale et l'intercollectif
durant les mouvements de grève
le je pense que la réelle problématique
se donner réellement les moyens à
l'hôpital public de pouvoir assumer ses
missions de service public est
clairement à l'état actuel des choses il
n'est plus capable de pouvoir les
assumer
merci beaucoup grégory chakir porte
parole du collectif inter bloc
infirmiers au chu de toulouse